Wendy and her husband were spotted in
New York today putting on a united front
back together guys even with the babies
still together I find you're gonna leave
him Wendy Wendy stepped out with her
husband today wearing her wedding ring
all this after multiple reports that her
husband's alleged mistress just had a
baby girl and this comment last Thursday
marriages are not easy and don't ask me
about mine until you see this Vaughn a
source close to Wendy show tells et that
after Monday's broadcast Wendy did not
return to her sober living facility but
instead started drinking and ended up in
the hospital and today after recently
taking two months off another twist we
have a planned break coming up next week
I know what plan though but we're back
with live shows on April 8th wendy has
been married to Kevin hunter for 21
years he's also her manager and the
executive producer of her talk show
despite the fact that he owned a salon
and had no TV experience before he met
her our source says quote he controls
all aspects of her life
I asked Wendy's longtime friend Paul
Porter about their marriage why do you
think Wendy continues to stay with Kevin
I know Wendy loves her husband they
built an empire together
Kevin's bless he never finished the
ninth grade and they built tens of
millions of dollars together now you
told me Paul that Wendy hired a private
investigator and found out about cars
about an office and also a house yes see
she went over to the house to see if it
was true and she found out it was true
that's part of the paying Kevin she's
been seeing this for almost two years
now do you think Wendy will ever leave
him I think you know with the birth of
the new child things are destined to end
this is really something else now I
talked to Kevin hunter last week and he
did not want to discuss his mistress or
the babe I'm sure he didn't no no he
said he was focused on Wendy's sobriety
okay she said don't ask until the rings
off the Rings off it was awkward
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]